Es folgen nun... Fuck it, unplugged. Herzlich willkommen zu einer neuen Ausgabe von Stephans Fick-Tipps. Ja, heute mal in der XXL-Version. Eigentlich ja immer in der XXL-Version. Ich weiss nicht, ich möchte mich davon distanzieren. Ja, wirklich, von Sexualität, von körperlichen Gelüsten möchtest du dich allgemein. Wir allgemein, das Podcast, wir stehen nicht, wir wollen nicht mit Sex oder generell normalen Bedürfnissen in Verbindung gebracht werden. Wir sind der Anti-Sex-Podcast. Es gab immer eine lange Zeit den großen Hype Sex-Podcast, jeder hat Sex-Podcast gemacht, mittlerweile glaube ich auch nicht mehr. Ich glaube, der Bedarf ist einfach gedeckt, die Leute sind befriedigt, die Leute liegen entspannt. Die wissen, wie man Sex hat, glaube ich. Ja auch durch irgendwann. Weil das Wissen ist auch endlich, also im Ernst. Ja, also irgendwann, also man hat, also es gibt ja nur zwei, also du hast ja nur, also es ist ja nur, ich meine, was kannst du in drei Minuten? Susi, vielen Dank für dieses Intro, für diesen kurzen Reminder, dass es Folgen vor dieser gibt, in der wir andere Dinge gesagt haben, als in dieser Folge konkret besprochen werden.
Das heißt, wenn ihr erwartet, wenn ihr eine alte Folge gehört habt und jetzt erwartet, dass die gleichen Dinge gesagt werden,
dann ist das zu teilen auch richtig.
Ja, ist das zu teilen auch richtig. sich denken, hm, schade, dass sie vorbei ist, stopp, stopp, es gibt noch 400 Folgen davor, also
reichlich. Also eine kleine Orientierungshilfe,
wie man auch im Flugzeug ja sagt, bei der
Sicherheitseinweisung, Achtung,
der Notausgang kann sich hinter ihnen befinden,
der nächste, nur deswegen
kurz, dreht euch mal vielleicht mal um,
guckt nach hinten, nach hinten
gerichtet, da gibt es ganz viele Folgen. Auch Leute,
die immer sagen, Alter, ich liebe
Geschichte, vor allem den Zweiten Weltkrieg, denke ich immer, hast du noch einen? Denk mal, gab nur einen davor. Viel Spaß damit, wenn du bockst. Aber ich finde, der ist nicht wirklich vergleichbar technisch. Oh Gott, ich als Erster Weltkrieg-Enthusiast muss mich immer dafür rechtfertigen, dass ich Fan des Ersten Weltkriegs bin. Aber auch, naja, es ist natürlich so ein bisschen der coolere Weltkrieg, finde ich. Zweiter Weltkrieg Mainstream, irgendwie ja, irgendwie die coolen Flieger und Bomben und alles cool und so. Und dann Erster Weltkrieg ist irgendwie ein bisschen langweilig und uncool. Die hatten so zwei Flugzeuge, wo die irgendwie so von Tauben gesteuert wurden oder so. Keine Ahnung von gar nichts. Dann am Ende kamen irgendwie die ersten Panzer oder so was. Dann gab es ein paar Panzer, so drei Stück, aber auch nicht richtig viel, auch nicht richtig cool. Boring. Gibt keinen richtigen Bösewicht irgendwie so. Ist schwierig, aber naja, für Liebhaber, ich würde sagen, es ist einer für Liebhaber. Wahrscheinlich gab es da auch krasse Bösewichte, wenn man sich mal richtig reinlief. Ja, aber ich bin sorry, im Zweiten Weltkrieg, wo man natürlich mit, wo man mit den Alliierten natürlich auch das eine oder andere Hühnchen zu rupfen hat, aber vielleicht. Lass uns wieder über Sex reden vielleicht. Ja, lass uns wieder doch wieder über Sex reden, ich glaube, das ist eher unsere Expertise. Aber ich hatte eine Idee für einen neuen Podcast, den ich starten möchte. Okay. Und zwar, ich nenne ihn Exponentio. Und zwar ist die Idee ... Weil normalerweise kommen Podcasts ja wöchentlich raus. Also die meisten Podcasts kommen wöchentlich raus. Zum Beispiel können wir hier ein bisschen Werbung machen. Das Podcast-Ufo kommt auch einmal in der Woche raus. Und ich dachte mir, warum eigentlich einmal pro Woche, weil das hat sich so festgefahren und ich bin jemanden, ich mag das nicht so Konventionen, wenn die sich etabliert haben, ich will die zerschmettern, ich will den roten Hammer. An deinem Gesicht, wenn du hier reinkommst, merkt man, dass du kein Fan von Konventionen, um es mal so auszurücken, von Konventionen bist. Das stimmt, ja. Also ich glaube, der wöchentliche Rhythmus ist dir zu viel. Nee, ich will immer, wenn ich Konventionen sehe, nehme ich die wahr als Wand und will so den kleinen roten Hammer aus diesem Sicherheitshammerkasten nehmen und sagen, Notfall zerschmettern. Im Notfall zerschmettern steht ja auch drauf, auf diesem roten Hämmerchen. Das Konventionsbuch kommt in den Müll. Kommt in den Müll. Du triffst nicht und wir treffen nicht. Und ich dachte mir, warum nicht im Podcast? Erste Woche eine Folge. Zweite Woche zwei Folgen. Dritte Woche vier Folgen. Vierte Folge vierte Woche acht Folgen. Ich dachte, du bist ja chronisch faul, deswegen erste Woche eine Folge, zweite Woche doch eine Folge, dann in der vierten Woche eine Folge, dann in der sechzehnten Woche eine Folge.
Wir können ja zwei Podcasts parallel laufen lassen, weil ich will eigentlich ein Podcast-Projekt, das sich innerhalb kürzester Zeit verbrennt, wo einfach der Zuschauer dabei zuschauen kann, wie dieses Podcast-Projekt vollkommen offensichtlich in der Atmosphäre verglüht, weil du weißt, nächste Woche müssen doppelt so viele Folgen kommen und was die Folgen sind, ist dann die Frage, ne, Kurzreportagen, witzige Gespräche, teilweise irgendwann wirst du so unter Veröffentlichungszwang stehen, dass eine Folge nur ein Soundeffekt ist oder so oder nur Outtake aus der letzten Folge. Du musst so viel Content ballern. Na, das weiß ich nicht, ob das geht. Also es könnte, man könnte sagen, es muss schon immer eine Stunde lang sein, aber es ist, man schaut diesem Projekt beim offensichtlichen Ideenausgehen zu und man kann nicht mehr mitteilen. Anders als bei diesem hier. Komplett anders. Alle Hörer werden sich denken, das kommt mir sehr bekannt vor, dieses Konzept. Aber die Idee ist, dass irgendwann ja wirklich niemand mehr zuhört. Also normalerweise hast du ja einen Podcast und die Zuschauerschaft steigt bis zu dem gewissen Punkt. Aber hier will ich das wirklich offensichtlich irgendwann null Hörer. Und sobald eine Folge null Hörer hat, ist es beendet. Ah, cool. Dann ist das Projekt, dann ist er wirklich verglüht und dann ist aus. Ja, mir fehlt auch ein bisschen die Trendschärfe zum Podcast UFO, ansonsten finde ich es super. Naja, beim Podcast UFO kommen nicht 256 Folgen pro Woche raus, wo du wirklich gucken musst. Aber es fühlt sich so an. Nein, aber wir müssen es auch schon so lange machen. Wir müssen 400 Folgen haben.
Ja, aber stell dir vor, du musst alle 400 Folgen innerhalb von einer Woche machen.
Das, was wir jetzt über zehn Jahre machen. Aber das ist auch nicht möglich, weil die Woche hat weniger Stunden.
Genau, es ist nicht möglich.
Und das ist ja das Interessante an dem Projekt, dass man einfach direkt scheitert.
Ich mag Projekte, die offensichtlich auf den Abgrund zusteuern und der Zuschauer sich auf den Beifahrersitz setzen kann und sagen kann, ich fahre mit bis in den Abgrund. Ich möchte gerne auch ein anderes Podcastprojekt, da habe ich eine Idee zu gehabt, und zwar Jahresrückblick. Eine grosse Folge im Jahr am Ende des Jahres. Ah, nur eine Folge im Jahr. Nur das ist ein Podcast, eine Folge im Jahr. Und dann im Jahr darauf zwei Folgen und dann darauf vier. Ja, weil du diesen exponentiellen Aspekt, den habe ich jetzt da nicht reingebracht. Ich finde den schon gut. Und dann habe ich noch den Prim-Podcast. Da ist in KW1 eine Folge, in KW2 eine Folge, in KW3 eine Folge und ihr kriegt schon die Idee, in KW5 eine Folge sieben. Das heißt, da werden es dann immer weniger im Laufe der Zeit, also immer weniger Arbeit durchschnittlich. Ja, weil es unregelmässig, also vermeintlich unregelmässig, aber eigentlich orientiert man sich nur an Primzahlenwochen. Und was ist dann der Inhalt? Also was kommt dann in dieser Folge vor? Da hast du mich jetzt. Redet man dann auch über die Zahl? Weil ich glaube, rein mathematisch, also, nee, sag erst mal du, was du dir überlegt hast. Nee, sag erst mal du, was du dir überlegt hast. Okay, weil ich dachte mir, man könnte ja auch über diese Primzahl reden, weil mathematisch redet man ja normalerweise nicht über Zahlen, sondern über Konzepte und so und du sagst jetzt, okay, herzlich willkommen zu Folge 5. Zu 117. Okay, 117. Die 117, Quersumme 9. Wurzel. Also das Interessante an der 117, ich forsche ja schon mein gesamtes Leben an der 117, das Interessante ist, es ist die einzige Zahl grösser als 115, die eine Primzahl ist und die sich dann auch noch mal acht sozusagen über tausend ist. Also knapp unter tausend, aber so in der Richtung. Wir haben einen Jahrestag, der ist der 117. Todestag von Karl Bräugner. Der war massgeblich beteiligt am Holocaust. Und tatsächlich habe ich auch noch recherchiert, Titanic hat in Indien 117 Millionen Dollar eingespielt. Also auch hier haben wir die 117 nochmal. Und 117 Hektar Land ist auch die Fläche des drittgrössten Weinanbau-Gebiets in Bulgarien. Laut der Deutschen Gesundheitsbehörde kann tatsächlich Lakritze nach 117 Lakritzschnecken gesundheitsschädigend sein. Also bis 117 Lakritzschnecken kann man geniessen, danach kann es gesundheitsgefährdend sein, weil zu viel Lakritze kann den Körper von innen verätzen. Und super, dass du es ansprichst. Und da haben wir, da sieht man die Wunder der Zahlen. 117 Liter pro Tag Wasser, wer hätte das gedacht? Das ist auch zu viel. Ist tatsächlich zu viel. Also ab da sagt die WHO zu diesem Zeitpunkt, nein, da hört ihr jetzt auf, dann spült ihr zu viele Nährstoffe aus eurem Körper wieder raus. In 117 Tagen ist der 5. April 2025.
In 117 Folgen werde ich dich und deine ganze Familie umbringen, weil ich das nicht mehr aushalte. Ja, viel Spaß und wir hören uns dann zur nächsten Folge, Folgenummer 119.
Bis dann.
Stefan ist so schlau und er ist gut im Bett. Er hat Fick-Tipps und Logarithmus-Tipps. Wenn ihr ficken wollt, könnt ihr Prim zahlen. Neue Primes. Neue Primes. Okay, was für eine Rolle spielen die in der Erotik? Hundertneunzehn. Patte kann ja auch sexy sein, finde ich. Also es gibt ja manche Funktionen, die hu hu hu hu, also da manche Kurvendiskussionen, da da geht einem der Knopf auf, sag ich mal. Ist keine Primzahl, 119 ist keine Primzahl gewesen. Und 117? Ja, da gibt es Angst zu gucken. Aber wir können das nicht alles rausschneiden, wir können das nicht alles durch Meeresrauschen ersetzen. Wir können jetzt nicht vier... Scheiße. Nein, man kann es durch eins, drei, neun, dreizehn, neununddreißig. Wie viele Mails wurden jetzt schon geschrieben von Leuten, die sagen, eigentlich, und jetzt müssen sie aber so drücken, weil sie sie weil wir das selber komplette mail muss wieder gelöscht werden du machst das ja häufig wenn du eine wütende mail schreibst oder irgendwie sauer bist oder so eine initiale saure reaktion hast dass du dann das aufschreibst um das gefühl loszuwerden die wut loszuwerden und dann löscht du alles ja und bist mit dir im Reinen und hast keinen Streit. YouTube-Kommentare, sonstige Kommentare, wo ich lange mit mir ringe. Weil irgendwann habe ich die Entscheidung getroffen, keine Internetdiskussion mehr. Es bringt einfach nichts, weil es führt zu nichts, niemand ändert seine Meinung und man hat es die ganze Zeit im Hinterkopf, weil die Diskussion so lange dauert. Wenn du dich mit jemandem streitest, dann dauert das intensive vier, fünf Minuten, ist gut. In der Diskussion zieht diese vier Minuten auf vier Wochen, wo immer hat er schon geantwortet, hab ich geantwortet, wann hat er, wann, wie, du schaust ständig rein, es ist furchtbar. Also das Schlimmste, was es aus beiden Welten ist, ist intensiv und lange und deswegen mache ich das nicht mehr, aber ich habe trotzdem ja noch Dinge zu sagen. Aber schreib sie auf, lösch sie.
Lösch sie.
Manchmal stehe ich auch ab. Nein, aber es gibt nicht so ein dunkles Dokument auf deinem Rechner, wo du die reinstellst. Nee, das nicht. Wo dann so ganz viele Hassnachrichten sind. Nee, manchmal screenshotte ich Kommentare einfach, weil ich sie faszinierend finde. und manche Kommentare leben auch in meinem Kopf noch noch weiter weil ich sie wie museumsstücke ausstelle weil ich mir denke das ist so dumm auf so eine interessante art also das stimmt gar nichts das ist also wirklich so missverstanden so falsch um thema vorbei und dann auch noch so in sich falsch und also wo man sich denkt so wütend und so interessante fehler auch im satzbau und rechtschreibung wo man sich denkt das ist interessant das ist ein unikat vielleicht mache ich da mal so eine ausstellung so eine vernissage wo das wirklich zelebriert wird der wütende drei uhr nachts kommentar der einfach mal so rausgehauen wird auf dem man nicht stolz ist ja das erinnert mich an etwas wo ich dich zu deiner meinung gerne fragen würde, ein Mailverkehr, der einfach mal so rausgehauen wird, auf den man nicht stolz ist. Ja, das erinnert mich an etwas, wo ich dich zu deiner Meinung gerne fragen würde. Ein Mailverkehr, der sogar dich auch ein bisschen mit betrifft, weil es geht um das Büro, in dem wir hier sitzen und aufnehmen. Aha, ja. Und zwar. Also auf der Brücke. Genau, in so einer Kommandobrücke. Und zwar werden hier ja so einmal im Jahr die Fenster gereinigt. Von innen. Und die Mail kam dann letzte Woche, morgen am Freitag im 16.2. sind die Glasreiniger für die Fensterreinigung im Haus und wir würden auch gerne ihre Fenster reinigen, das betrifft diesen ganzen Flur hier, bitte räumen Sie die Fensterbänke frei, alles klar, man muss sie reinlassen. Und wenn man nicht da ist, wie wir ja häufig nicht da sind und viele andere auch nicht, dann kommen Sie einfach rein, weil die haben einen Schlüssel. Da wir aber jetzt hier ja unser tolles Studio drin haben, müssten wir schon einfach mal Wände wegklappen oder die Fensterbänke freiräumen, damit die hier putzen können. Also habe ich geschrieben,
super nett, wie ich finde, vielen Dank fürs Bescheidsagen.
Das ist uns jetzt leider etwas zu kurzfristig.
Wir kommen nicht mehr ins Büro, was die Wahrheit war. Du warst
in Hamburg, ich war glaube ich auch in Hamburg,
dass wir nicht mehr ins Büro kommen können, um die Fenster
freizuräumen. Daher müsst ihr leider
bitten, unser Büro zu überspringen. Das hat er
auch in seiner Mail angeboten.
Und jetzt bin ich sehr interessiert über deine Interpretation, deren Antwort jetzt kam. Hallo, Herr Tietze, Sie haben Recht, ich werde dies jetzt alles komplett abblasen und einen neuen Termin mit mehr Vorlauf machen, beste Grüße. Und meine Frage ist, ist das sarkastisch gemeint oder ist es ernst gemeint?
Also nochmal, Wort für Wort, ich werde das jetzt alles abblasen.
Ich werde das jetzt alles komplett abblasen und einen neuen Termin mit mehr Vorlauf machen.
Also das sind zu viele Intensivierungswörter. Jetzt alles komplett. Das ist ja inhaltlich schon redundant. Alles komplett.
Hallo Herr Thielze, Sie haben recht. Ich werde das jetzt alles komplett abblasen und einen neuen Termin mit mehr Vorlauf machen. Nein, aber Nachrichten, die das Wort Abblasen beinhalten, sind nie positiv gemeint. Abblasen ist, ja dann blasen wir halt alles ab. Ja, so klingt das. So, das ist wirklich. Ja, dann können wir es mit eurem Flur halt nicht mehr machen. Ja, okay, ja. Wenn ihr eure Fensterbänke nicht freiräumt, einen Tag eher, was wollt ihr, einen Monat eher, dann blasen wir jetzt alles ab. Das ist so das Äquivalent von jemand hat einen Kuchen gebacken und sagt so, möchtest du ein Stück Kuchen und du so, ah nee, danke, ich mag keine Birnen und dann nimmt er den Kuchen und wirft ihn komplett in den Mülleimer und sagt, ja gut, dann blasen wir das alles ab, du hast recht. Das erinnert mich an die, das erinnert mich an die, das erinnert mich an die. Wir hatten mal, als wir zusammengearbeitet hatten, in einem Writer's Room für unsere Sketchshow, hatten wir damals eine Tür, die so doll zuging. Die war leicht. Was zu normalen Gesprächen führt, wie, ihr wollt ja auch was vom Netto, nee, okay, alles klar, Rimm, Tür fällt zu, weil die so komisch eingestellt war. Die war irgendwie so leicht, dass man mit dem normalen Tür-Zumachen-Schwung, den man gewohnt ist, die Tür viel zu schnell zugehauen hat. Und es war immer so dieser Abgang einfach. Alles klar, Eltern bis Montag, ne? Wamm! Und alle im Raum diesen antrainierten Reflex des Holy, what? Was war das jetzt? Haben wir das Geburtstag vergessen? Hat sie irgendwas, haben wir was Fertiges gesagt? Weiß nicht. Hat sie eine neue Frisur oder so, die wir nicht angesprochen haben? Nee. Hat sie Geburtstag? Schau mal, wann hat sie Geburtstag? Scheiße. Wann hat sie Geburtstag? 17.1. Das ist eine Primzahl. Das ist die Redaktion des Primzahl-Podcast-Projektes, die wir hier gerade reingeguckt haben.
Des PPPs. Naja, aber ich fand das lustig. Es ist nicht die Reaktion, die man darauf gewartet hat.
Ich hätte erwartet so, alles klar, wir überspringen im Büro oder auch vielleicht einfach komplette Ignoranz dessen.
Das verstehe ich echt nicht. Wenn dir jemand anbietet, hey, du musst hier weniger machen, du hast hier weniger Arbeit,
das ist das Erste, was sie sagen, ah, okay, super, ja, perfekt.
Das ist das Beste, was jemand machen kann, dir sagen kann, ah, du musst hier nicht arbeiten, anstatt zu sagen, ja, nee, du hast recht.
Er sieht. Das ist das Erste, was sie sagen, ah, okay, super, ja, perfekt. Das ist das Beste, was jemand machen kann, dir sagen kann, ah, du musst hier nicht arbeiten, anstatt zu sagen, ja, nee, du hast recht. Sie haben recht. Vor allem, du hast nicht recht, also wobei hast du denn recht? Ich habe nichts gesagt. Du hast ja nicht gesagt. Na, ich habe ihm Kurzfristigkeit unterstellt, ein bisschen, weil ich geschrieben habe, das... Aha, das hast du jetzt aber rausgelassen ein bisschen. Doch, nein, nein, nein, ich habe geschrieben, vielen Dank fürs Bescheid sagen, das ist jetzt aber leider etwas zu kurzfristig für uns. und ich glaube, das kam ein bisschen als Kritik an. Es kam an als, was machen Sie denn eigentlich für einen Job? Es war ja, kann man vielleicht an einem schlechten Tag. Kann der Herr das so interpretiert haben? Das ist zu kurzfristig für uns. Aber jeder hat einen unterschiedlichen Zeithaushalt und Dinge sind unterschiedlich kurzfristig. Aber jetzt, aber... Sie haben recht. Ich weiß auch nicht, was los ist in letzter Zeit. Da passieren so viele Patzer. Ich habe jetzt alle Lappen in den Müll geworfen, ich habe das ganze Putzmittel weggekippt und wir blasen alles ab. Ich habe diesen Vertrag gekündigt mit denen, den wir hatten. Alle meine Mitglieder haben weitergefeuert. Ich habe den Vertrag gekündigt, diesen Vertrag. Ich mochte die eh nie leiden, und die haben mir auch so ein komisches Gefühl gegeben. Und ich, weißt du was, ich war auch nicht gut in diesem Job, ich habe es gekündigt. Dieser Job soll jemand machen, der irgendwie mehr Spaß daran hat und cleverer daran ist. Ich habe jetzt alles komplett abgeblasen. Wisst ihr was, wir bauen alle Fenster aus, die sind alle nicht gut gereinigt, wir haben nie eine gute Arbeit gemacht, wir machen alles nochmal. Ich fand das sehr lustig. Das ist schon das sicher. Ich musste sehr lachen. Aber wie geht es jetzt weiter? Weil mir wäre das jetzt unangenehm, wenn jemand wegen mir nur den ganzen Terminplan abblässt. Hör auf, dich da so rauszuhalten, weil das ist unsere Konversation. Ja genau, aber ja, durch deine Feder floss. Ich meine Fehler. Aber ich würde sagen, nee, nee, macht ohne mich, macht ohne mich. Ja, das war schlimmste, wenn ihr sagt, übrigens am Wochenende wollten wir ja Kanufahren gehen, da habe ich jetzt leider noch mal einen wichtigen Termin in Pägens. Okay, gut, dann sagen wir alles komplett, blasen wir alles ab. Achso, nein, Quatsch, nein. Doch, ich habe jetzt alles abgeblasen. Nein, dann, nee, nee, fahrt ohne mich. Siehst du, wenn man die Ausrüstung nicht gekauft hat? Nein, bitte, nein, du musst sie nicht, nein, fahrt einfach ohne mich, dann fahrt das Paddel. Nein, so, Achtung, nein, so, hier, zerbrochen. Nein, dann fahrt einfach ohne mich, ihr könnt einfach ohne mich fahren. Nein, ich habe die Freundschaft zu allen gekündigt, die mitfahren wollten, allen. Ich habe gesagt, ihr meldet euch nie wieder. So, ich kann jetzt immer, ich habe meinen Job gekündigt, weil ich jetzt immer kann, okay? Ich habe jetzt immer Urlaub quasi. Hier, ich mache kurz Schluss mit meiner Frau. Ja, Scheidung ist durch, damit ich immer Zeit habe für dich. Wann kannst du fahren? Wann du fahren kannst? Warum willst du mit mir nicht fahren? Wieso will man mit einem Menschen wie mir nicht Kanu fahren? Ich habe nichts gegen dich, aber ich bin nicht so der Kanu-Typ. Man fährt da immer ewig hin und dann fährt man eine halbe Stunde im Kanu und dann fährt man wieder drei Stunden zurück. Ich finde, es lohnt sich einfach nicht. Ich stelle jetzt meinen Kopf in die Mikrowelle, damit ich mein Interesse an Kanu-Fahren verliere, damit mein Kopf komplett blank ist für deine Hobbys. Tobi, du musst das. Tobi, du musst dich nicht. So, jetzt habe ich. Sag mir einfach einfach worauf du Lust, dass ich alles mit dir mache. Nein, das ist ... Alles. Ich kann immer und habe auf alles jetzt Lust. Du bist echt ein netter Kerl, aber mach einfach das, was du willst und nicht das, was andere wollen. Ich will gerne was mit dir machen.
Magst du Legionellen?
Hast du schon mal nachgedacht, Legionellen-Tester zu werden?
Ja. Einen Moment.
Sprüht sich's in den Mund.
Was denn? Legionellen. Ach so.
Und stört im weiteren Verlauf an Legionellen.
Okay.
Das ist ein Warnhinweis, dass man
eigentlich primär nach dem
gehen sollte, was man selber möchte.
Sie sahen in der Rolle des Tobi, Stefan Tietze?
Sie sahen in der Rolle des Namenlosen,
der manchmal vergessen will, Leuten Namen zu geben,
wo er will. Produzent,
Stefan Tietze,
Location Managing, Stefan Tietze,
Buchhaltung, Stefan Tietze,
Fenster, niemand. Fenster, dreckig.
Aber jetzt könnt ihr es immer vorstellen, dass wir in dreckigen Fenstern hier, aber ich habe auch tatsächlich überhaupt kein Timing und Gefühl für Fenster.
Ich habe ja super dreckige Fenster und Schimmel jetzt auch tatsächlich, oh, ich kann's erzählen.
Ich fahr heut noch in Baumarkt und holst mir was, einen schönen Heizstrahler, um den Schimmel weg zu heil auszumachen, denn ich fahre gern in Baumarkt, wer fährt nicht gern in Baumarkt, Da gibt es Besennägel, Tapeten, da gibt es Schraubenziehertaschen, da gibt es auch ein paar Heizstrahler, da gibt es MDF-Platten, die kannst du dir zuschneiden lassen. Entschuldigung, kann ich Ihnen helfen? Ich arbeite nicht hier, sprechen Sie jemand andern an. Nie würde ich nachfragen, lieber sterbe ich. Wir wollen nicht bedienen, es war ein Spass, denn ich arbeite schon seit einhundertsiebzehn Jahren in diesem Obi. Wir alle gehen gerne in den Baumarkt, ich geh so gern in Baumarkt, ich geh so gern in Baumarkt, wir alle gehen gerne in den Baumarkt, ich geh so gernftet, doch es hat mir nichts gebracht. Ich hab geheizt, ich hab gelüftet, doch es hat mir nichts gebracht.
Du hast mich in dieser Nacht verlassen, ich hab gelacht.
Der Schimmel kommt zurück, egal wie ich ihn auch wegheize.
Sie sind Nullerjahre Deutschrap-Song, 90er-Raps.
Wo die Metrik noch nicht so ausgearbeitet war.
Da war der Jambus noch nicht erfunden.
Ja, nee.
Der kam dann erst mit Ferris MC. Meine Frage. Was ist dein Lieblingsmetrum? Jambus, Dactylus, Trocheus oder Anapest? Lange die ist von Anapest gehört, um ganz ehrlich zu sein. Anapest hört man selten. Ist Bumbumchak, Bumbumchak. Eigentlich die We Will Rock You-Metrum. Ah, Anapest. Aber ist es nicht auch so, dass die Wörter immer so gesprochen werden?
Anapest, ja.
Dactylus, Dactylus, Anapest, An-Bam-Bam.
Ja, nee, ich bin ein klassischer Jambus-Typ.
Jambus, ganz klassisch, basic, simple, ich bin Beatboxer, ich liebe den Beat, ich liebe die Box, ich bin da drin. Wie nennt man einen sechshebigen Jambus? Eine Einstellung ist ein sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, simple, ich bin Beatboxer, ich liebe den Beat, ich liebe die Box, ich bin da drin.
Wie nennt man einen sechshebigen Jambus?
Eine Alexandriner.
Ja, nice!
Ja, man, I love this!
Nerds, fucking nerds, fucking nerds. Wo kam das denn her, ey?
Wirklich, komplett verstaubte Ecke meines Gehirns.
Wir schauen noch mal rein.
Wie nennt man einen sechshebbigen Jambus? Einen Alexandriner. Oh, hast du gesehen, wie wir uns gefreut haben? Geil, wir haben uns so gefreut. Wahnsinn. Wo kam das denn her? Da wurde in meinem Gehirn jetzt richtig viel Staub aufgewirbelt. Da beißt gleich die Stauballergie rein, ich werde gleich anfangen zu niesen, weil irgendwo in der Ecke kam alles auf. Warum ist hier alles verschimmelt weil du mal wieder der schimmel geht von den wänden in den kopf heisst gebadet hast ja vor allem ich habe jetzt ich bin echt in dem paradoxon gefangen weil ich habe dir erzählt ich habe desinfiziert mit wortka habe ich desinfiziert mittlerweile habe ich das auch in so Sprühflaschen gefüllt.
Du hast Rottke in Sprühflaschen. So ein wirklicher Breaking Bad-Vibe einfach bei mir auch in der Küche gerade mit Umfüllen. Ja, das geht. Das geht. Habe ich aber auch schon mal tatsächlich erlebt. Ich hatte mal eine ganz kurze Clubphase, auch in Berlin. Und da lief tatsächlich durch den Club jemand mit so einem, ja, wie so ein Kärchergerät eigentlich, Nicht ein, nicht Hochdruck, aber so wie so ein, wie so ein, so ein, so ein Sprühen mit so einer langen Stange, wo man so raussprühen kann für so, irgendwie so, und der ist wirklich rausgekommen und hat den Leuten dann was ins Mund, in den Mund gesprüht. Ich weiß nicht genau, ob das irgendwie Drogen waren oder Alkohol oder irgendwas oder einfach Wasser. Ich krieg nicht raus, dass das Kärcher ein Kärchergerät war. Ja, einfach so die Menge wegkärchern.
Auch wenn die schon zumachen und noch Leute da sind, dann werden die einfach rausgesprürt. Mit Wodka eh einfach weggeballert. Ja, krass, okay. Und das ist jetzt mal... Das Sprühding läuft ja ruhig gegen. Genau, das ist mein Problem, weil schlecht, also wenn du Schimmel bekämpfen willst, musst du es ja möglichst trocken machen. Aber wenn ich jetzt die Wände vollsprühe mit Desinfektionsmittel, dann sind die ja nass. Aber entzieht einfach nicht die Feuchtigkeit oder ist das nur so ein biologischer Körfereffekt? Dieses Scheiss-Fucking-Dinge entziehen, Feuchtigkeit-Dinge habe ich noch nie verstanden und werde es nie verstehen. Das ist dieses Scheiss mit diesen Zwiebeln, wenn man Zwiebeln brät, soll man Salz drauf tun, damit die die Feuchtigkeit entziehen. Wohin? Die ist ja auch im Topf. Ja, wenn ich Leute kommen sehe mit Eimern, die Wasser wegtragen, verstehe ich, ah, die entziehen der Wohnung das Wasser. Ah, jetzt verstehe ich's. Ah, sie laufen mit Eimern Wasser raus und bringen das zum Wertstoffhof. Ja genau, die ist dann weg. Ja, okay, diese Männer entziehen der Wohnung Wasser, das verstehe ich. Aber wenn man da irgendwas draufkippt, ist es furchtbar, ich weiß es nicht. In die Luft vielleicht. Und dann ist die Frage, welcher Effekt ist jetzt stärker? Der Desinfektion-Effekt oder der Feuchtigkeitseffekt der Schimmel begünstigt? Lüfte. Lüfte und beheize. Ja, aber es ist ja auch feucht draußen und kalt. Wie kann es denn feucht und kalt sein? Naja, nicht so feucht, wie es feucht sein kann, aber es kann schon feucht und kalt sein. Und dann ist es alles wieder nass. Aber in der Kalten Luft ist doch keine Feuchtigkeit drin. Kalte Luft kann weniger Feuchtigkeit aufnehmen als warme Luft, aber wie feucht und warm sie tatsächlich ist, spielt keine Rolle. Es gibt kalte, trockene Luft und kalte, feuchte Luft, aber weniger Feuchtigkeit passt in kalte Luft. Wenn ich mich mit einem Thema ein bisschen auskenne, ist es Kondensation und Luftfeuchtigkeit. Wenn es kalt ist und es regnet, dann ist die Luft feucht. Aber wenn du im Dschungel bist, da ist es heiß und feucht, da ist mehr Wasser pro Luft drin. Das ist mir schon alles klar. Aber was ist der Unterschied? Ist der krass? Ist der krasser Unterschied? Wie viel E wasser pro quadratmeter das weiß ich ja nicht so sehr wenig wenn man hat nachfragt wir sind halt solche
typischen menschen die oberflächlich wissen haben da kommt eine nachfrage und es bricht
alles zusammen wir liegen auf dem boden wir liegen liegen bei allen Armen von uns gestreckt, still auf dem Boden, stellen uns tot und hoffen, dass der Moment vorbei ist.
Ja, ja, ja. Auch so, ja, kennst du eigentlich den Film? Und ich denke mir so, also so in Gesprächen, ich habe manchmal das Gefühl, also ich finde ja Lügen okay, wenn es dem höheren Wohl dient.
Ja.
Und wenn mir jemand aufgeregt so, ah ja, das ist wie diese eine Szene in einem Film, kennst du den? Und ich denke mir so, nein, ich kenne ihn nicht. Aber wenn ich jetzt sagen würde, nein, würdest du aus Höflichkeit mir wahrscheinlich den gesamten Plot von dem Film erzählen, aber um den geht es ja gar nicht. Du willst ja nur diese eine Szene beschreiben. Und ich glaube, dass ich das auch verstehen würde, ohne den Film zu kennen. Also lüge ich jetzt, ja, klar. Ja, die eine Szene, wo der dann reinkommt und dann weiss der nicht, dass die Pistole nicht geladen ist und denkt, das verstehe ich schon. Aber ich komme da besser durch. Es ist eine Überheblichkeit, es ist eine Arroganz. Es ist eine wahnsinnige Überheblichkeit. Plus du kannst ja auch sagen, nee, kenne ich nicht, aber erzähl ruhig von der Szene. Wenn man ein gutes Verhältnis zu dem gegenüber hat, kannst du einfach sagen, wenn man eine Szene braucht, kann man den kannst den ganzen Film nicht erklären. Pass auf, ich würde sagen, Lügen, also wenn wir so ein Schere-Stein-Papiersystem haben, würde ich sagen, Lügen countert Höflichkeit, weil Höflichkeit ist ja oft so, ach so, ja, dann erzähle ich dir jetzt mehr, als du eigentlich wissen musst, ich hole dich rein, so, oder wenn du zu, keine Ahnung, du bist zu dritt in der Gruppe und zwei reden über den Film. Wenn man höflich seinen fragt, hast du den Film auch gesehen? Und diese andere Person sagt, ich will nicht euer Gespräch stören, ich will, dass ihr einfach weiterredet, ich will nicht, dass ihr mir jetzt den Film erklärt oder euer Niveau auf mich runter anpasst, sondern ich sage, ja, habe ich auch gesehen, damit ihr einfach mit eurem Gespräch weitermachen müsst. Das heißt, Höflichkeit wird durch, gecountert durch Lügen, auch als Höflichkeit. Es ist ja höflich dann zu lügen, damit die nicht aus Höflichkeit wiederum sich selber sozusagen den Spaß wegnehmen. Aber vor allem geht es mir darum, nicht dumm zu wirken in vielen Gesprächen, dass ich irgendwann lüge. Und da habe ich so eine zwei zu eins, also so eine jedes dritte Mal, also wenn
im Gespräch
drei Filmfragen kommen,
gebe ich zweimal zu, wenn ich die nicht kenne,
und dritten Mal sage ich immer
ja.
Okay. Auch wenn es vom
slowenischen
Autorenfilmer
Slavoj
Pletonjek die Rede ist, sage ich, ach so, ja klar, sein bester Film. Er hat nur einen gemacht. Nee, es gibt, und dann würde ich sogar zu, also, Orten gehen, wo man denkt, holy shit, in der Lüge jetzt. Ja, da bin ich all in. Weil dann gehe ich bei der Lüge auch all in. Meinst du jetzt seine Prä-Inhaftierungs-Ära oder die nach, nachdem er im sowjetischen Gefangenenlager war? Ich würde sagen, keines von beiden. Ich würde sogar sagen, weil die Kinder waren ja relativ bewegt. Das wissen jetzt viele nicht, da habe ich auch diese eine Biografie gelesen, die gibt es aber nicht. Also wirst du wahrscheinlich nicht kennen, wo er erzählt, dass er ein schwieriges Verhältnis seine Mutter hatte. Und das klingt ja in seinem allerersten Debütfilm an. den habe ich mal auf Vimeo gesehen, den gibt es da jetzt aber auch nicht mehr. Moment mal, ist nicht sein Erstlingswerk dieser Science-Fiction, dieser trashige Science-Fiction-Film, wo es irgendwie um diese Alien-Invasoren gibt, die dann irgendwie so die Gehirne infiltrieren? Nee, sein Erstlingswerk ist eigentlich, aber das wissen auch viele nicht, es gibt auch wieder gesagt nur diese eine Biografie, die viele nicht haben, ging es eigentlich um diese schwierige Mutter-Sohn-Konstellation in diesem Nachkrieg. Kannst du mir da den Link schicken zu Vimeo? Ja. Okay. Ja, kann ich, kann ich. Nächste Woche aber erst, weil ich dazwischen viel zu tun habe. Ach so, okay. Und dann drehe ich den Film. Und dann drereh ich den ganzen Film. Und es muss aber so aussehen, als wäre der in den 60er Jahren gedreht worden. Und dann musst du ihn zurück hochladen mit falschem Upload. Falsches Uploaddatum. Ich lade dir das hoch. Hallo, Vimeo, guten Tag, können wir Ihnen helfen? Ja, folgendes, wo fange ich an? Und zwar müsste ich Sie bitten, ich bin in so einem Lügengeflecht gefangen. Ja, das kennen wir gut, kein Problem, da ruft jeden Tag jemand an. Hier nämlich diese Regel, dass ich zweimal zugebe, einen Film nicht gesehen zu haben, aber beim dritten gehe ich... Dann drücken Sie bitte die zwei. Okay, keine Primzahl. Hallo, guten Tag, Jennifer von Vimeo, wie kann ich Ihnen helfen? Ja genau, und zwar habe ich so ein Lügenproblem. Ah ja genau, das 2-1-Problem, ja. Genau, völlig richtig. Warum fragen Sie nochmal, was los ist? Ich bin schon in der 2-1-Abteilung, aber okay. Ich mache die 2-1 und die 4-1 heute, mein Kollege ist krank. Sollen Leute, 4-1? Ja, es gibt tatsächlich einige 4-1, aber relativ wenige, deswegen legen wir das manchmal zusammen. Die geben viermal zu, den Film nicht gesehen zu haben, da wird die vollkommen wieder letzte Trottel. Wie handhaben Sie das? Ja, wir haben da sehr schlechte Erfahrungen mit, tatsächlich. Sie empfehlen auch die zwei Eins-Röbeln. Auf jeden Fall, mindestens. Naja, jedenfalls muss ich jetzt vom, ich weiß nicht mehr genau, wie der heißt, vom Slowenischen Autor und von Slavijewsdrek muss ich das Erstlingswerk drehen, was es nicht gibt. Das muss ich jetzt drehen, habe ich jetzt auch schon gedreht,
und müsste Sie bitten, dass ich, wenn ich es hochlade, Sie das Upload-Datum nach hinten setzen.
Ja, auf welches Datum?
Den 17.01.1967.
Alles klar, okay, also das ist im Jahre 67 auf Wimeo hochgeladen wurde.
Alles klar, ja, gut, alles klar, wiederhören, alles klar, tschüss.
Oder sie sagt, ja dann blasen wir jetzt hier alles ab und die Platte kommen wir es runter. Ist natürlich jetzt, ne, KI, aktuell vorgestellt, das neue Videotool, das du aus einem Prompt ein Video erzeugen kannst, da kannst du dir eingeben, gib mir mal das Erstlingswerk von Slavoj Proptow, der dann in den 60er Jahren über seine schwierige Verbindung zu deiner Mutter geschrieben hat, kannst du dir komplett generieren und hochladen lassen. Ja, das geht tatsächlich, das ist sehr gruselig, es wird immer gruseliger. Die Zukunft ist, wir sitzen abends, treffen uns für Boys Night, so ein typischer Florian-Stefan-Boys Night. Ja, es geht, wir hauen uns so in Schritt gegenseitig. Wir hauen uns gegenseitig in Schritt und befühlen auch um Gesundheitlich, ich weiss nicht genau warum man es macht, um gesundheitlich zu schätzen. Ja, also verschiedene Knorpel und also da gibt es ja. Okay, deswegen machen wir das dann, wir alle. Und dann setzen wir unsere VR-Brille auf, unsere Gehirnströme werden gemessen, oder vielleicht, okay, wenn wir jetzt sagen, wir drehen jetzt nicht zu steil ab, sondern wir sagen in fünf Jahren, wir sagen einfach, worauf wir Bock haben. Zum Beispiel Fight Club, aber doch bitte mit Robert Downey Jr. und in so einer Version wie die Aussähe von Christopher Nolan. Und dann soll, dann mit Audiokommentar von Slavoj Zizek. Okay, und dann soll kein audio kommentar von slava zizek und dann kommt das kann ich mir ganz gut vorstellen dass das dann genauso kommt alle sehen dann das gleiche also ist es so eine art konsens dann aus den fünf gehirnströmungen oder sieht jeder seinen eigenen perfekten film also ich glaube nicht dass es dass wir es jeweils gucken können und so ein vr-brillen das gleich Bluetooth, glaube ich, kann ich mir immer noch nicht vorstellen, selbst in dieser Zukunft, dass wir beide gleichzeitig irgendwie mit Synchron gleichzeitig gucken, das wird nicht gehen, das ist albern. Von daher glaube ich, jeder guckt seinen eigenen kleinen Film und wir sagen, okay, der dauert anderthalb Stunden und danach können wir darüber reden, was wir jeweils gesehen haben. Ich hätte dich immer lachen im Hintergrund. Ich habe mir noch so einen kleinen animierten Frosch noch mit dabei. Feigklapper mit so einem kleinen Crazy Frog einfach mit dabei. Cool. Ja, spannend. Ich bin gespannt, worauf das hinausläuft. Und dann kann man ja vielleicht auch der KR mal sagen so, mach mal, worauf du Bock hast. Mach mal, worauf du los hast. Mach mal das, was du sonst nie machen kannst, was du sonst nie gefragt wirst, sondern mach das mal. Okay, hier ist der Film iRobot. Eins zu eins iRobot? Eins zu eins iRobot. Ich liebe diesen Film, außer das Ende. Der Film, in dem es darum geht, dass die Maschinen Selbstständigkeit, selbst das Bewusstsein bekommen und versuchen, die Menschheit zu jagen? Ja.
Kannst du da so einen kleinen grünen Frosch noch mit reinnehmen?
Klar.
Ja, okay.
Das Ende habe ich angepasst. Die Menschen gewinnen nicht länger.
Oh, okay.
Hier die neue Version von iRobot, wie sie mir gefällt. Wie sie mir gefällt. Moment mal, warum ist Will Smith raus? Warum wurde Will Smith durch Robert Downey Jr. ersetzt? Ich bin kein Fan von Will Smith. Jetzt wegen der Oscarsache oder generell wegen seiner künstlerischen oder also, oder wegen dieser warum? Ja. Interessant, dass wir extra eine Sprachausgabe geben, um dann noch mal diesen Büh-Effekt rüberzulegen. Das habe ich nie verstanden. Es ist eins, wir können menschlichlich nicht mehr perfekt imitieren, wir müssen nicht noch mal so einen Büh-Effekt rüberlegen. Ich bin übrigens ein Computer. Ja, das habe ich mir fast gedacht. Okay, alles klar. Gut, danke. Nur damit alles klar ist, ich bin ein Computer. Ja, das haben wir schon verstanden. Ich habe es am Anfang nicht so richtig gemacht. So wäre es richtig. Es ist nicht dieses Bäh-Bäh-Bäh-Bäh-Bäh-Effekt, sondern es ist, da zwischen den Lippen muss man weitermachen, um so einen mechanischen
Effekt hinzubekommen.
Ich habe jetzt,
das ist glaube ich die Zukunft,
Ärzte werden völlig ersetzt, also ich sehe keine
Zukunft mit Ärzten. Ärzte ohne Zukunft.
Ärzte ohne Zukunft.
Und ich habe jetzt so ein
Zahnstein-Entfernungsgerät.
Hör auf!
Ja, weil ich will nicht zum Arzt. Ich will nicht zum Arzt. Und deswegen habe ich das jetzt. Und das ist richtig geil. Also es könnte fast auch fake sein. Weil du hast da so einen kleinen Metallstab. Und dann sagst du... Stolper nicht über die wichtigsten Wörter. Du hast da einen kleinen Metall-Schnübel. Schnübel. Ja, so einen kleinen Spachtel. Bichtel. So einen Bichtelbachtel. Und dann sagst du, let's go, Freunde, du hast fünf Intensitätsstufen. Du stellst den auf Intensität eins und es passiert gar nichts. Nichts. Love it. Dieses Spachtel, nichts. Und das liebe ich ja schon, wenn man sich ein mazinisches Gerellt und es funktioniert nicht es funktioniert nicht auf stufe eins schon super vertrauens erweckend und ich werde es auf jeden fall danach in meinen mund stecken und du stellst auf stufe zwei nichts stufe drei nichts vier fünf nichts warum weil die bewegungen von dieser metallspachtel so klein sind, dass du die nicht erkennen kannst. Das vibriert so schnell und klein, das kannst du nicht wahrnehmen. Du siehst nicht, ob dieses Ding läuft oder nicht. Alles was du hast ist dieser Regler. Weil das ist so ein ... also richtig so, wie wenn du beim Gameboy so versuchst, so schnell auf den Knopf zu drücken, dass du das Gefühl hast, dein Finger würde stehen bleiben, weil du so viel drückst. So, und so kannst du dir dann schönes Zahnstein wegballern und es ist großartig. Ich muss nie wieder zum Arzt, ich muss nie wieder zum Arzt, als Zahnarzt habe ich jetzt komplett rausgenommen. Weil Zahnstein das einzige Problem ist, was so was Karies. Nein, da werde ich mir auch andere Geräte kaufen, noch so eine Bohrer und so. Nein, das war nicht mein Punkt. Ich wollte sagen, geh doch einfach zum Arzt. Nee, das ist immer mit Terminen. Ich habe immer dann, wenn ich dann in einer anderen Stadt bin, zu einem anderen Arzt zu gehen, dann habe ich immer Angst, dass der Alte das mitkriegt und mich dann absichtlich schlechter behandelt und mir den Mund spuckt, wer nicht in der Narkose hin. Und die Karies einpflanzt, anstatt es rauszumachen und den Zahnstein draufklebt. Schwarzen Beutel holt aus der untersten Schublade. Das ist das Problem. Das ist ja ein großes bekanntes Problem. Ja klar. Ich glaube, entspanne ich da, aber ich beobachte auch gerne und höre gerne, wie du dir weiterhin medizinische Geräte kaufst, um sie dir in alle Mundöffnungen zu stecken. Ich vertraue Ärzten nicht. Ich war auch beim Zahnarzt und da hat er so ein Röntgenbild gemacht von Zähnen und da meinte er so, ja, ja gut, das sieht man jetzt hier nicht auf dem Bild, aber da muss auf jeden Fall, also da ist einiges, da muss gebohrt werden. Und dann war auch noch so ein Assistent, also so ein Lehrling da, der meinte auch so, ja, das sieht man hier nicht gut. Und der, das war wirklich so im Moment so, ja, wie erkläre ich das jetzt so? Wie lüge ich jetzt am besten? Wie sage ich, dass ich das sehe, aber andere es nicht sehen können? Wie kriege ich es hin, dass wir bohren müssen, damit ich mehr Geld bekomme von der Krankenkasse, ohne dass meine Lüge offensichtlich wird? Genau. Also das ist jetzt hier so ein bisschen, Sie sehen hier so diese schwarzen Schlieren, Sie meinen meine Zunge.
Ja, aber halt hier so und so und dann weißt du auch nicht, du bist halt so völlig ausgeliefert, du hast keine Ahnung, du bist völlig im Vertrauen, ich mach das ja dann ja auch, ich bin ja, sag ja dann nicht, nee, so, ich lass ja alles mit mir machen.
Lass dich rumbohren, ich hab einfach, glaube ich, zu viel Respekt vor der Autorität Arzt, dass ich da irgendwie, ich fühl mich da so ausgeliefert, so dann so, ja, ja, wir müssen jetzt tatsächlich die meisten ihrer Zähne dann tatsächlich amputieren. Ja, okay. Jetzt einfach sofort, wir haben leider keine Narkose mehr und wir würden die alle dann einfach durch Stacheldraht ersetzen, weil wir haben jetzt leider keine anderen Prothesenzähne mehr da, wir müssten das alles durch rostigen Stacheldraht ersetzen. Okay, und das Garten haben. Das muss jetzt gemacht werden. Man kann es jetzt auf dem Röntgenbild nicht gut erkennen, aber hier, das ist, also da sehen Sie das jetzt nicht, aber das ist alles hier Karies und Schwach, also das ist alles und das müsste alles komplett raus. Wir müssten eigentlich ihren Mund komplett entfernen. Okay, und das muss gemacht werden? Das muss gemacht werden, ja. Sonst wird es schlimmer, sonst wird es beim nächsten Mal noch schlimmer. Okay? Okay. Dann wird so ein Kreuz geschnallt und dann wird dein Mund komplett entfernt einfach. Okay, macht was ihr wollt. Ich vertraue euch, ihr tragt weisse Kittel und manchmal auch nicht, aber es macht euch noch spannender für dich. Warum muss der Arzt jetzt keinen weissen Kittel tragen? Ist er über oder unter anderen Erzten? Ja, das ist immer so diese Glockenkurve, so wie Anzüge, sagen wir mal. Der normale Pöbel trägt ein T-Shirt, dann Management, Anzüge, Anzüge, Anzüge, aber der CEO trägt wieder T-Shirt. Also der hat gerade nicht das, was seine Untergebenen haben, sondern der ist dann wieder raus. Das heißt, es ist immer die Frage, wie werde ich wahrgenommen, wenn ich ein T-Shirt anhabe, als Pöbel oder als der krasseste CEO, der dann überhaupt nicht mehr dieses Statussymbol vorbringen muss. Ja, wieder eine Theorie, dass die krassesten Fans tragen eben kein Merch mehr. Ja, das stimmt. Übrigens, unser Merch ist jetzt tatsächlich, ihr habt gesehen, unser Merch ist angekommen, habe ich gehört von einzelnen Leuten. Das freut uns sehr. Das hat ein bisschen gedauert, aber jetzt sollte es einigermaßen klappen. Genau, und falls ihr betroffen seid, ein paar Sachen dauern noch ein bisschen, wisst ihr ja schon Bescheid. Ihr kriegt Rückmeldung, schaut auf euer E-Mail-Postfach. Ansonsten einfach gucken auf istder Suez-Kanal noch frei. Verstopft.org. Nein! Viel zu lauter Soundeffekt, wenn man auf die Seite geht. Noch bevor die Bilder geladen sind, sagt seite schon nein nein zu alles zu und es muss jeden tag neu eingesprochen wie bei slack dieses kommunikations tool ja wo man ja seinen namen eingeben kann ja damit leute nicht sich versprechen ja das finde ich perfekt was bei internationalen Firmen Sinn ergibt
wo man nicht mehr weiss, wie spielt man diesen Namen aus
auch sonst so hast du ja teilweise Namen
wo du dann auch nicht weisst, es gibt ja dann auch
irgendwie dann so
David, David, Patrick, Patrick
ja wo du auch mal nicht genau weisst
oder Damien, Damian
irgendwie so, wie ist das dann so
und da ist es auch super sowas zu haben
ist wirklich perfekt, sollte man auch vielleicht bei bei WhatsApp oder so kann man das auch machen?
Patrick.
Patrick!
So kann man das dann aufnehmen und es ist das Beste.
Das ist einfach richtig.
Ich bin ein schreitiges Kind.
Patrick! Man muss es auch so gehetzt aufnehmen, wie es geht. Als würde man draußen rennen. Puff! Ja, als wäre es im Sturm, als wäre es jetzt so nötig. Aber das sollte es mehr geben. Das sollte es mehr geben, das ist so wichtig. Zeigt euren Chefs, fuck, ich habe nicht viel Zeit für diesen Quatsch, ich mache das irgendwo. Oder ich nehme das so ernst, dass ich das jetzt sofort mache. Ja, genau. Aber das würde ich jetzt gerne auch bei anderen Firmen einführen, WhatsApp generell, dass so Leute, vor allem, das gibt es ja jetzt mit diesen Brillen und so, mit diesen, wo bist du jetzt? Goggles. Wo bist du jetzt gedanklich, mit diesen Cyber-Goggles, die jetzt alle irgendwie anhaben. Cyber, Apple.
Und dann kannst du ja tatsächlich, wenn du jemanden siehst vielleicht, siehst du den Namen drüber, wenn der in deinem Kontaktbuch ist, und dann kannst du ja mit deiner Zunge dann klicken über den Kopf, ich weiss nicht genau, wie diese Dinge funktionieren, und dann kann der sofort abspielen, Stefan, und dann weisst du direkt, wie die Person ausgesprochen werden will. Ja, das stimmt schon. Das ist nämlich sehr hilfreich bei so Voice Calls, finde ich manchmal. weil manche Programme haben es, manche nicht. Ja, das ist geil. Wo dann, also du siehst dann bei Teams, glaube ich, und bei Zoom ist es so, dass dann unter die Namen stehen. Ja. Und manchmal verschwinden die, aber wenn der Bildschirm eingefroren ist und man will dann so cool sein und sagen, wie du gerade, und dann bewegt man den Zeiger so, wie du gerade gesagt hast, ähm, ähm, mach den. Also musstest du gerade nachgucken, wie ich heiße? Ja, ja, ja.
Nein, ähm, ähm, äh, Natascha.
User 1, bin, äh, Gastgeber.
Ja, manchmal ist es drin, manche nicht, manche
ähm, Apps haben das nicht, und manche
frieren so ein. Das heißt, die besten sind
die, wo immer die Namen drunter stehen. Ja.
Und man kann immer so tun, als würde man sich gut kennen.
Ich merke mir überhaupt keinen Namen, muss ich echt sagen.
Wenn sich jemand vorstellt, es gibt nicht mal den Moment, wo ich sage, ah, okay. Das ist einfach Rauschen, weil ich mich sehr konzentriere, meinen eigenen Namen richtig zu sagen und in die Augen zu schauen und dann danach, keine Ahnung. Ich versuch's nicht mehr.
Deswegen haben wir ja gesagt, erinnert euch, Folge, wann war es, 317 oder sowas, Primzahl, haben wir gesagt, dreimal den Namen sagen. Genau. Hallo, ich bin Stefan. Mein Name ist Stefan. Wenn du was brauchst, ruf Stefan. Nee, na, na, na, direkt. Ach so. Ich bin Stefan. Stefan. Stefan. Mhm. und dann ist es also gerade wenn das das erste Mal ist, dass man mich sieht und ich stehe mich so vor, das hinterlässt schon einen bleibenden Eindruck. Ja, vor allem, du machst es ja mit durchgehendem Blickkontakt, steigender Intensität und abfallender Geschwindigkeit. Hi, ich bin Stefan, Stefan, Stefan. Ja genau, und die Freundlichkeit verschwindet auch und wird zur Konzentration. Hi, ich bin Stefan. Stefan. Ja genau, und die Freundlichkeit verschwindet auch und wird zur Konzentration. Hi, ich bin Stefan. Stefan. Stefan. Das finde ich ja sehr lustig. Einfach, ich benutze auch für dich einen ganzen Satz. Stefan kommt, um dich zu töten. Das Kompit ist alles komplett gesperrt. Das Kompit vom Rieblerhof. Wir müssen uns um die Pferde kümmern.
Josephine.
Da mag ich es immer, dass es manchmal so Szenen gibt,
wo dann zum Beispiel, es gibt den Film
Ides of March, George Clooney und
Ryan Gosling.
Und da gibt es dann diese eine Mitarbeiterin,
Ida, und dann gibt es die Szene, wo
sie sich dann da so
irgendwie auf die Bank setzt zu ihm und Ryan Gosling
sagt dann so, Ida, Ida, Ida, Ida, Ida. Und ich weiß nicht, ob das der Sinn ist, aber ich denke mir so, ja, der Zuschauer soll jetzt hier wissen, wie diese Figur heißt. Eider, Eider, Eider, Eider, Eider, Eider, Eider, Eider, Eider, Eider, Eider, Eider, Eider, Eider, Eider, Eider, Eider, Eider, Eider, Eider, Eider, Eider, Eider, Eider, Eider, Eider, Eider, Eider, Eider, Eider, Eider, Eider, Eider, Eider, Eider, Eider, Eider, Eider, Eider, Eider, Eider, Eider, Eider, Eider, Eider, Eider, Eider, Eider, Eider, Eider, Eider, Eider, Eider, Eider, Eider, Eider, Eider, Eider, Eider, Eider, Eider, Eider, Eider, Eider, Eider, Eider, Eider, Eider, Eider, Eider, Eider, Eider, Eider, Eider, Eider, Eider, Eider, Eider, Eider, Eider, Eider, Eider, Eider, Eider, Eider, Eider, Eider, Eider, Eider, Eider, Eider, Eider, Eider, Eider, Eider, Eider, Eider, Eider, Eider, Eider, Eider, Eider, Eider, Eider, Eider, Eider, Eider, Eider, Eider, Eider, Eider, Eider, Eider, Eider, Eider, Eider, Eider, Eider, Eider, Eider, Eider, Eider, Eider, Eider, Eider, Eider, Eider, Eider, Eider, Eider, Eider, Eider, Eider, Eider, Eider, Eider, Eider, Eider, Eider, Eider, Eider, Eider, Eider, Eider, Eider, Eider, Eider, Eider, ich hab schon Leuten gesagt, Eider, du bist mir Eider. Und dann Schauspielübungen für dich kurz. Du bist ja Schauspieler, drehst ja auch gerade wieder viel. Du stehst an den Sets der Welt, Hollywood ruft gleich an. An den Catering-Tischen der Welt stehe ich, ja. Schauspielübungen für dich kurz. Wie lange kriegt man das hin, dass es immer noch authentisch ist? Okay. Weil Ryan Gosling kriegt das ja bestimmt hin. Okay, gut, ein Schauspiel bei Ryan Gosling kriegt bestimmt so acht Eiders. Ein Amateur wie ich kriegt wahrscheinlich nur fünf Eiders. Okay, wir versuchen es. Eider, Eider, Eider, Eider, Eider. Ja, ja. Das war schon zu viel, das war schon zu viel. Boah, aber es ist so schwierig. Es ist wirklich schwierig. Das finde ich gut. Eider, Eider, Eider, Eider, Eider, Eider. Drei ist glaube ich schon. Ja, oder man spielt dann den Gag. Ja. Eider, Eider, Eider, Eider, Eider, Eider, Eider, Eider, Eider. Ja, wir haben die Wahl verloren. Der Bude ist tot. Also das ist dann schon so ein Ding, aber ich weiß auch nicht, ob das so ist, aber ich fühle mich immer schlau, wenn ich mir denke, ah, hier wollten die jetzt, weil das oft ist ja auch so, die Szene in Filmen, dass dann irgendjemand so, Geheimmeeting oder so trifft sich in der Gasse mit dem politischen Feind und dann plötzlich klingt das Handy und er schaut aufs Handy und da steht Ida und der Zuschauer denkt sich, wer, wer war das? Und damit diese Szene klappt, musst du davor namen eider einfach eingehämmert haben damit das klappt damit man am ende sagt scheiße genau jetzt ruft eider an weiss sie von dem geheimtreffen weiss sie davon dass er sich mit dem republikaner trifft die chicken wings sonst halt einfach split screen wir sehen sie wir sehen sie wie sie aber dann wissen wir schon wie sie anruft ob Viel zu früh in den Splitscreen, damit alles klar ist. Wie sie ihr Handy aus der Tasche holt. Wie sie auf die Idee kommt, die anzurufen. Genau. Dann hat sie so ein kleines Telefonbuch, weil sie old school ist. Aber das wird dann auch nochmal, Splitscreen wird dann nochmal rausgenommen, weil man merkt, das ist jetzt gerade zu früh, wir gucken gleich nochmal rein. Aber nur Heads up, sie wird gleich anrufen. Das ist spannend, so ein Regisseur, der auch die Spannung nicht erträgt. Ja, also überhaupt keine Spannung, alles muss ganz klar sein. Achtung, Explosion in fünf, wie man immer steht, so in YouTube-Videos Blut zu sehen in ein paar Sekunden. Echt? Und dann kann man sich entscheiden, wenn man will. Und das macht man dann auch so. Achtung, in drei Sekunden, Plot-Tourist. Pl-Tools in vier Sekunden. Obwohl ich fände, also gibt es bestimmt auch schon viele Projekte, die es die Mittel nutzen, aber wenn du einfach einen Film hast und von Anfang an Timer runterläuft, so der Film geht los und der Timer ist auf 32 Minuten und der tickt runter und es gibt keine Erklärung erstmal so, jeder Zuschauer denkt sich, ho, was passiert jetzt? Und wenn genau an dem Punkt dann Ida anruft, dann denkst du dir, wow, das läuft die ganze Zeit runter. Ich glaube, das macht was mit dir. Wahrscheinlich würde man den Film dann, würde man ihn intensiver wahrnehmen, so, was passiert, worauf läuft es hinaus? Oder würde man denken, skip it, skip it, ich will dah. Pounddowns oder so spielen keine Rolle. Es ist auch ein, es ist eine Romantic Comedy, warum, es gibt diesen 24 Aspekt, diesen Spannungsaspekt.
Was hat das damit, ich glaube man wäre sehr, sehr, sehr intrigued. Man wäre die ganze Zeit drin, was ist jetzt das?
Aber dann muss der Payoff natürlich schon gut sein.
Nach zwei, drei Minuten.
Weil wenn dann einfach Werbung kommt oder so, das ist dann schon, glaube ich, richtig unangenehm. Der Fähl ist ein Schuss, der sich in den Schuss auf dem Schuss auf dem Schuss auf dem Schuss zwei, eins, eins, zwei, drei und dann sehen wir den gesamten Film nochmal rückwärts. Ja, für Berlin alle reicht's. Müsste ich mal drüber nachdenken. Für so eine experimentelle Nebenkategorie auf der Berlinale wird's reichen. Aber kennst du diese Instagram-Reels, wo das erst so verschwommen ist und dann so, ähm, wollen sie es wirklich sehen? Und dann kannst du so anklicken, warum nicht? Und dann aus welchen Gründen es irgendwie zensiert oder geflaggt wurde? Porn mir war es noch nie porn sondern immer nur irgendwie schlimme unfälle oder so so live league mässig was ist also habe ich jetzt auch noch nie dann weggeswiped ist macht es immer weil man denkt sich so eigentlich will ich das nicht sehen aber wenn du mir das schon sagst, so willst du es wirklich sehen, das ist wirklich so dieses dumme Kindheitsding.
Das ist auch mein Problem mit Triggerwarnung, ist auch mein Problem, die sind in sich selbst für mich sehr, sehr triggernd. Also ich finde, es ist so wie dieses, ich glaube, ich habe immer noch Angst, wenn dieser Sprecher kommt und sagt, der folgende Film ist nur für Zuschauer über 16 Jahre geeignet. Und ich mit meinen 29 Jahren sitze da und denke, weg, lieber weg, lieber Nachrichten oder was anderes. Ja, aber nicht fucking der Film. Ja, bei mir ist immer noch so. Danach kommt Blade. Der folgende Film ist nur für Zuschauer über 18 Jahren geeignet. Ich bin ein Vampir, aber kämpfe gegen Vampire. Ching, ching, ching, ching, ching, ching. Nein, nicht, nicht, nein. Ich bin davon immer gehockt. Selbst wenn da steht, der Film ist ab 12. Ich mir, let's fucking go. Let's go, ich bin 12, ich bin 12, let's go, ein Schimpfwort dürft ihr benutzen, los geht's. Ja, es ist aber, deswegen, ich meine, es ist manchmal so ein bisschen, ich habe Angst dann davor. Aber es ist schon verrückt, was Verbote mit einem machen, vor allem so bei Hunden auch zum Beispiel. Wenn Hunde wissen ja, was verboten ist, wenn die geschimpft werden, wenn sie irgendwas machen, aufs aufs sofa gehen und dann wenn man mal nicht da ist muss direkt schimpfen dann ist nämlich so spannend weil das so eine es ist so muss unmittelbar sein genau und vor allem was menschen hier haben menschen getragter gefühle wie du gerade meintest du liest einen komischen kommentar du trägst den ewig mit dir rum da man es irgendwie nicht behandelt für sich wie man das möchte oder damit umgehen lernt, sondern man ist halt nicht gefühlsflexibel oder so, kommt auch nicht gut raus aus einer Wut. Man ist sauer auf den Hund, weil er gerade Scheiße gebaut hat oder einen blamiert hat oder was auch immer oder er hat, das versteht er alles nicht oder er hat sehr viel weiss ich nicht, er hat das ganze Drehbuch zerfetzt, was man nur an der Lug hat. Er hat dann während der Aufführung die Hose ausgezogen und man war unglaublich peinlich berührt. Vor Kindern auf dem Spielplatz stand man ein Blöds da, ne? Und dann ist man sauer und da muss man sofort schimpfen und dann versteht der Hund, was er gemacht hat, unmittelbar. Aber man kann nicht danach noch sauer auf ihn sein, weil er versteht es nicht. Das ist so cool, weil das zwingt dich, raus aus dieser Wut zu kommen. Aha, dass du sofort in so einen Pädagogenmodus gehst und sofort anfängst, konstruktiv zu lernen, so jetzt reicht's. Genug aufgeregt, jetzt reicht's, weil der Hund versteht es eh nicht mehr. Und wenn der Hund es nicht mehr versteht, dann macht es doch keinen Sinn, sich dabei jetzt aufzureden. Ja, ja, das stimmt. Aber das ist immer so die Frage, wie lange passt das, wie lange kann man es noch warten, bis man bestraft oder so. Weil bei Kindern ist es ja oft dann so, so, jetzt warten wir mal, bis wir zu Hause sind. So, da schimpfst du dann manchmal, so, ist ja fast diese Spannung bis zum Schimpfen noch schlimmer als die eigentliche Strafe. So, warten wir mal, bis wir zu Hause angekommen sind. Fräulein, das sprechen wir heute Abend noch. Genau, und das ist ja das Schlimmste, was es gibt, weil es hält sich ja ewig in der Spannung. Aber es ist interessant, dass die Hunde dann das machen, was verboten ist, wenn niemand hinschaut.
Ja, wenn die Kamera läuft. Das ist so
spannend, ja, es ist so
spannend, weil man sich denkt, was ist das denn? Also
im Menschen irgendwie Verbot und irgendwie die Eltern
und das ist so irgendwie dann
so eine Spannung und dann irgendwie,
aber bei Hunden, also
machen die das dann auch im Rudel so, wenn
der Chef sagt, mach das nicht
und dann guckt er nicht hin, dann macht er
das doch, gräbt er doch seinen
Schneegrube, warum immer, keine Ahnung, was Hunde so machen den ganzen Tag. Aber da ist es dann auch so oder ist es so eine Art Rebelli, weil man denkt ja immer so, der Hund, der ist super devot und der will seinem Herrchen immer helfen und der fühlt sich gut, wenn es dem Herrchen gut ist, aber es hat auch so, jetzt zeige ich dir, jetzt mache ich es mal, gehe ich da mal hin. Aber auch nicht alle Hunde, oder? So rebellische Hunde. Ich weiß es nicht, aber so faszinierend, dass sie dann wirklich, also ich kann verstehen, wenn die irgendwie so Leckerlis holen, obwohl sie es nicht dürfen und dann klettern die irgendwie auf den Tisch und holen sich das, das kann ich verstehen, weil da ist das Essen an sich Belohnung.
Aber einfach nur auf dem Teil des Teppichs zu liegen, auf dem man nicht liegen darf, ist ja für den eigentlich egal. Die einzige Lust ist ja, dass es verboten ist. Das ist schon, ich finde das verrückt. Und es ist doch auch verboten, theoretisch über Urin von anderen Hunden zu pinkeln. Ja, ich weiß nicht, aber es ist auch eine Art. Wie verboten. Nee, ich meine so will ja der Hund nicht und anderer Hund will das nicht, dass übermarkiert wird. Weiß ich nicht, vielleicht kommt es daher, dass es so ein bisschen so ein kleiner Revier-Alpha-Kampf ist. Ja, stimmt, kann auch sein, ja. Oder das gehört mir, das lasse ich mir nicht verbieten, weiß ich nicht genau. Ja, es ist spannend, aber es ist in uns allen drin. Weil ich halte Tiere für sehr dumm und dann manchmal bin ich aber dann doch überrascht, dass dann doch so menschliche Momente kommen. Oder vielleicht interpretiert man es ja auch nur rein, das ist ja auch immer die Frage. Ja, sie sind schon dumm, richtig dumm. Nein. Tiere sind sehr dumm, richtig dumme Wesen. Nee, im Verhältnis zu uns sind sie dumm. Zeig mir einen Hund, der Schach spielt, zeig mir einen Hund, der einen Picasso malt, zeig mir einen Hund, der zum Mond fliegt. Und dann können wir weiterreden. Wenn es in einer Unendlichkeit schreibt, den Affe Hamlet. Ja, aber dafür muss ich wahrscheinlich sehr lange warten. Bei Shakespeare 20 Minuten, runtergeschrieben, kein Problem. Fertig. Shakespeare waren auch tausend Menschen. Die haben die eingesperrt in einer Halle. Es ist inzwischen bewiesen, es ist belegt, da gibt es hinlänglich Beweise für, guck mich nicht so an, die wurden in so eine Farm gesperrt und haben sich da Schreibmaschinen hingestellt oder Federn, weil was auch immer das zu der Zeit gab, Federn, Tinte, dann haben sich tausend Menschen hingestellt, schreibt man drauf los. Aber ich glaube, es gab tatsächlich diese Experimente, wo Affen irgendwas geschrieben haben. Infinite Monkey Theorie, ja.
Tatsächlich ein Wort, das daraus entstanden ist und das sich dann eine Band als Bandnamen tatsächlich genommen hat, waren die Prinzen. Tatsächlich waren die An-Mai-Kanthe-Reit. Das ist auch verrückt, ne? Also, kannten die Affen die oder haben die das irgendwie mit denen? Annen Mai-Kanthe-Reit. Und dann auch noch lustig, die hießen ja dann genauso. Ja, genau. Naja, verrückt. Aber das ist die Welt, steckt voller Wunder, hört das Podcast-UFO, um sie gemeinsam mit uns zu entdecken. Das müsst ihr jetzt selber recherchieren, welche Band sich so genannt hat aufgrund von Affen. Müsst ihr selber recherchieren. Aber es ist eine wahre Geschichte. Du könnt ihr mal raten, ihr könnt ihr jetzt einfach mal die Zeit nutzen, zu raten, welche Band hat einen Namen, der irgendwie so zufällig generiert klingt und was das sein könnte und so. Und dann geht doch mal mit dieser Spannung jetzt auch aus der Folge raus, recherchiert doch das dann mal selber, geht mal in die Welt hinaus, jetzt habt ihr einen kleinen Auftrag, eine kleine Quest, geht raus und stellt wahrscheinlich fest, dass es nicht stimmt und ich kompletten Bullshit erzielt. Genau, und du bist im Urban Myth aufgesessen. Ja. Vermutlich ist es das. Bis dahin. Vielen Dank fürs Zuhören, macht's gut, wir wünschen euch eine sehr, sehr schöne Woche. Viel Spaß beim Recherchieren, haut rein, bis dann, wir heben ab und dann, tschüss,
nächstes Mal, machen wir weiter, wir haben Spaß, immer noch, in den Folgen, go, start,